معنى القلم نيويورك ستيفاندو جاريكا
المتحدث باسم الامين العام للامم المتحده
اهلا بك
يعني يونيسف تحدثت وقالت في بيانها او
وصفت الوضع في بيانها وضع هؤلاء النازحين
واللاجئين الذي
هو الاسوا حتى قبل وقوع هذه الكارثه والان
في اجواء شديده البروده تقع مثل هذه
الكارثه في وقت سيء كما قالت اليونيسف ما
هو شكل وطبيعه الجهود التي تقوم بها الامم
المتحده ومعها المجتمع الدولي للتعامل مع
تداعيات هذا الزلزال
سوف يحتاج لحشد كميات كبيره جدا من
المساعدات
لسكانه الجنوبي تركيا وشمال غرب سوريا هذه
كارثه جاءت
فوق ما كان يدور في شمال غربي سوريا
ارسلنا بعض فرق التنسيق والتقييم على
الارض وكان لدينا اكثر من 700 تعامل تابع
لدى في جنوب تركيا وشمال غرب سوريا وبدانا
بتوزيع المساعدات الطارئه بداتم بتوزيع
المساعدات الطارئه لكن هناك اكثر من حديث
ومن بين منظمه الصحه العالميه التي تقول
بان هناك صعوبه في وصول تلك المساعدات
الطبيه الى سوريا كيف تتعاملون مع هذه
الاوضاع مع هذا الوضع وصعوبه وصول تلك
المساعدات الدولي الى المحتاجين هناك
بالطبع انهم في غايه الصعوبه ليس فقط لانك
تتعامل مع زلزال بل زلزال في ظروف شتاء
قارص بامكانكم ان تتخيلوا صعوبه الموقف
كان لدينا مساعدات موجوده من قبل في شمال
غرب سوريا نقوم بتوزيعها وكانت لدينا ايضا
مساعدات موجوده في جنوب تركيا والتي نقوم
بتوزيعها دعما للسلطات في تركيا ونحن
بحاجه الى ايطاليا المزيد من المساعدات
لكن التحدي يبقى ماثرا لان المعابر
الحدوديه بين الجنوب تركيا وشمال غرب
سوريا فيه صعوبات لان الطرق المؤديه اليه
تعانت من ضرر وايضا الوصول من مناطق تسيطر
عليها الحكومه الى المناطق التي لا تسيطر
عليها الحكومه في سوره نواجه الصعوبات
فيها ايضا وقد اشرت الى هذه التحديات
المثله امامكم اليوم الصندوق الامم
المتحده للطوارئ خصص 25 مليون دولار
للمساعده لكن ما هي الاليات هل تملكون اي
اليات واضحه لايصال تلك المساعدات في ظل
تلك التحديات التي تحدثت عنها وباتت ماثله
امامكم
ان الخمسه وعشرين مليون دولار سيكون بدايه
للمساعدات التي ستوزع على عدد من صناديق
وبرامج الامم المتحده لايصال المزيد من
المساعد هذا مجرد بدايه لبدء
التشغيلي ماكينه المساعدات
وسوف نصدر نداء عاجلا سريعا
وساقول من الان سنحتاج الى الملايين
والملايين من الدولارات في القريب العاجل
لمساعدته هؤلاء النازحين واللاجئين لهذه
الكارثه
غير واضح كيف ستوصلون تلك المساعدات تحدثت
عن طرق متضرره تحدثت عن اغلاق معابر وهناك
ايضا معبر واحد فقط وهو باب الهوى هو
المفتوح والتي تقدم من خلاله المساعدات
الى تلك الم كيف ستوصلون هذه المساعدات
واي مساعي او اي دعم من السلطات التركيه
تحتاجونها
نعم السلطات الموجوده على الارض والتي
وايضا السلطات في تركيا تفتح الطرق لكن
كما قلنا كان لدينا بعض المساعدات
الموجوده من قبل واستطعنا تحريكه وتوزيعها
ونحن نقوم بذلك والامر نفسه ينطبق على
شمال غاب سوريا بالنسبه لسوريا سنحاول
ايصال المساعدات عبر الحدودي بمجرد ان يتم
اصلاح الطرق ونتوقع ان تمر طول القوافل في
الايام القليله القادمه عبر المعبر
الحدودي اذا يعني مع تعطل هذه المعابر
ومعبر واحد هو فقط الذي يمكن الوصول
مساعدات
عبر السيد دوجاريك يعني هناك ايضا مناشدات
رئيس الهلال الاحمر السوري ارسل مناشده
عاجله برفع الحصار كما قال والعقوبات
الاقتصاديه المفروض على سوريا للتعامل مع
تداعيات هذا الزلزال الى اي مدى يمكن ان
يستجيب المجتمع الدولي لمثل هذه المناشدات
العاجله
دعونا نكون واضحين نحن اعتقدنا دائما ان
العقوبات يجب ان لا تعرقل ابدا المساعدات
الانسانيه هذا موقف واضح للامم المتحده
ونعمل ان اللحظه الدمار والازمر والالم
هذه التي نمر بها سوف تساعد الناس على ان
يضعوا الاعتبارات السياسيه جانبا ما يجب
ان نركز عليه ليس السياسه بل الناس الذين
يحتاجون الى المساعده
اشكرك ستيفان دو جاريك المتحدث باسم
الامين العام للامم المتحده كنت معنا من
نيويورك